hi my name is Stephanie Mel faculty
chair digital analytics for simply
learned I'm a consultant I'm a teacher
I'm a speaker and I've been in the field
for several years let's talk about the
digital marketing evolution over the
years we've seen the marketing landscape
evolved into a very complex technical
environment there are different
technologies different tools but when we
think about it we can go back to the
core concepts of marketing those
concepts still prevail even in a digital
world so in this session we're going to
look at a couple of different points
that you can really look into in order
to get ready to evaluate things like
customer lifetime value do more advanced
segments better understand your
customers so we want to learn about
understanding the customer journey as a
starting point for acquisition
conversion onboarding and retention and
eventually expansion of your customer
base we want to target your customers
using advanced segments either from
personas or from product thinking and
finally we want to get you ready to look
at things like customer lifetime value